hey youtubers it's Charlie this week on
Game of Thrones dying is thirsty word we
also got one of the best Aria hound
scenes I think I've seen all season and
a whole bunch of stuff from the books
real quick announcement though there's
no new episode next week just because of
Memorial Day I will be doing a bonus
video though so be sure to subscribe to
get it if you're just finding me for the
first time to all the regulars round
seven of the giveaway begins now
remember all you have to do to
participate is post a comment on this
video and be a subscriber this episode
made me so happy for so many reasons so
let's start with top 5 moments and then
I'll do my review careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet but time to fly so number 5 the
hound explains his backstory to Aria it
was both heartbreaking and adorable to
watch The Hound lick his wounds like a
real dog but then he just breaks down
emotionally in front of Aria she had
just done her big nothing is nothing
dark Jedi and training speech so seeing
her be so genuine with him seemed a
little strange I love the two of them
together they push all the right fandom
buttons but if she were really turning
into a stone-cold killer she probably
wouldn't be feeling any sentiment for
the Hound at all and she wouldn't have
offered to treat his wound fire or no
fire also in case you don't remember we
heard that same story about the Hound
back during season 1 when there was that
tournament where he and the mountain
ended up fighting I think someone else
was explaining it to Sansa but they just
said how the mountain pushed the hounds
face into the fire when they were kids
I'm surprised given the similar family
upbringing that the Hound and Tyrion
never became friends both their families
just spent most of their lives [ __ ]
on them but Tyrion kind of learned to
deal with it by being quick on his feet
that being funny or kind of funny and
the Hound really just kind of turned it
all in word and it turned into this big
festering psychological wound you know
just like the one on his neck like he
literally wears his problems on his neck
now number 4 Melisandre and solis how
surprised were you that Melisandre just
copped to perpetrating a lot of [ __ ]
it seemed like 99% of her vials were
full of tricks but there was that one
the one that you do not want to touch I
do really wonder what's in that one vial
though also we cannot escape that scene
without staring at the black hole that
was her boobs
I enjoy nudity on Game of Thrones as
much as the next pervert but were you
surprised at how long the camera
lingered on
in the tub it's like Melisandre was
forcing Solis to look at her naked like
she has power over all flesh it's kind
of hard to tell if Melisandre was
trolling Solis or if she was just trying
to be nice she really did drop a huge
bomb though remember how last season she
talked about the power and royal blood
and then Gendry escaped I think they
might be changing things from the books
and taking Shireen with them because
Melisandre wants to use her for
something something not good so that's
not something that happens in the books
but I'm really interested to see where
they take that subplot so keep your eyes
on Shireen because she just got way more
important number three Podrick and
Brienne enjoy some hot pie I love hot
pie so much I'm so glad they brought him
back this early I actually just thought
they were gonna make a subtle reference
to Harrenhal in season two in the
Brotherhood in season three but they
went full-on and he spilt his hot by
guts all about Arya he could kind of
tell he must be a little bit starved for
conversation at the crossroads or maybe
he's just that chatty with all of his
customers that would be so funny I like
the idea of a chatty hot pie baking
direwolf bread and just enjoying his
simple life away from all the intrigue
like he's the only character on the show
that gets a happy ending that would just
be hilarious but this whole thing was a
giant win for Podrick because he's the
one that did the math and figured out
that the Hound was taking Arya to the
Eyrie when they were at the crossroads
did anyone else think that the bandits
would actually jump out and stab them
it's like anytime things get too quiet
and the characters start looking around
like they're lost I just expect a sword
to materialize inside their guts that is
what happens when you watch way too much
Game of Thrones you just start expecting
characters to drop like flies
number two Oberyn agrees to be Tyrians
champion the way they acted out that
scene and the music cues they use made
it feel like a huge battle had been won
like the end of episode five whenever
ghosts came back to John and you could
just hear the whole world cheering at
the same time I also really loved Oberyn
telling that story about him visiting
Casterly Rock when everybody's a little
kid that was straight out of the books
they actually really did visit Casterly
Rock whenever they were young there was
even that shout out from when Cersei
almost yanked off materia and stick I
went every time I read that part wow she
is horrible when is her reckoning coming
that's what I'm wondering if you didn't
see Oberyn was actually crying a little
bit whenever he was talking about using
Tyrians trial to begin his quest for
justice
the mountain is just the first person on
that list it sounds like he plans on
killing a lot of people not just
Lannisters I really loved the level of
detail that he went into when he was
talking about how Cersei was describing
Tyrion you know claws tail giant head I
feel like if Cersei had not been born a
Lannister she could have been an amazing
bar just telling the craziest stories
but my number one moment
Littlefinger makes Lysa fly all of the
Eyrie Sansa scenes were straight out of
the book from the snow castle of
Winterfell to the Littlefinger kiss to
the moon door they really sped that plot
up too because it's from book four and
back in King's Landing the trial is a
book three thing I totally don't mind
because that Littlefinger speech was so
great even though he is so creepy that
should actually be a contest see who
gives the best speech each season on
Game of Thrones that'd be a pretty tough
one to decide Sansa is really getting in
deep with Littlefinger now she had no
idea of what was going on with the
purple wedding but this time she had
ringside seats for Lysa flying out the
moon door
and remember she is a terrible liar and
they still have to deal with Robin
because he's still running around being
crazy
as long as Littlefinger can keep the
other Lords of the Vale from taking over
Robins stewardship Sansa will probably
be okay
Robin is very Joffrey like in his mood
swings and the moon door is always gonna
be a threat hanging over everyone's head
it's like the ultimate prison sentence
it's like the errands could just push
all their problems into a nice little
circular death hole but now it's your
turn let me know in the comments below
what was your favorite moment and for
all the book readers out there how do
you feel about the way they're changing
Arya and the Hound scenes like do you
enjoy that she's being so nice to him
now it's actually a change that I think
is really awesome just because they work
so well on camera I think that's why
they did that just they made his part
that much bigger just because it totally
works so just so we don't forget there's
a couple other big plots that we need to
talk about before I do my review first
off Daenerys is sending Daario to subdue
all the wise masters in young Chi I love
that he's so Restless he actually does
have desires beyond having sex with
Daenerys but yeah that look on her face
made me laugh so hard
HBO already said that Daario is gonna be
a regular in season 5 so obviously he's
not going to die but we'll have to wait
and see what happens with the wise
masters because they're one of the big
villains that Daenerys has to deal
with so the next big thing is the
defense of Castle black and Alliser
Thorne essentially ignores all of Jon
Snow's warnings he and Sam are basically
gonna go sit up on top of the wall until
that wildling raiding party comes but
they will be able to see them coming so
at least Jon will get that I told you so
a moment remember at Castle black is not
fortified from the south I actually
explained why in my bonus video from
earlier today so I'll have a link to
that in the description if you want to
learn more about it overall the episode
was actually pretty happy
despite some pretty shocking moments I
gave it an A - just because I want to
reserve a z' and eight pluses for like
one or two episodes of the season it was
really an episode of strong character
moments yes
Lysa flying through the moon door was a
shocking moment but the rest of the
episode was surprisingly positive I
couldn't feel better about the hound and
Arya it's like a few episodes ago she
thought he was the worst human being on
the planet and now she's taking care of
him even Tyrion and Jaime were acting
like they were little brothers trying to
play a prank on their dad like they were
two little boys just trying to get a
rise out of Tywin and that look they
shared it was like they were remembering
their entire childhood I always loved
the way the show mixes these really
strong character moments with the you
know ocean moondoor moments even
Littlefinger speech to Sansa was really
touching about getting revenge for
Catelyn and the red wedding he kind of
took back a lot of that goodwill
whenever he kissed her in that really
creepy way but for a minute his heart
was in the right place be sure to let me
know if you think there's any other
really big moments that you think I
forgot but actually I just remembered
lollies it's kind of dark when you think
about lollies character and what
happened to her that led to her being
married to bran but like I said no
episode next week so I'll be posting a
bonus video be sure to subscribe to get
it
my Q&A will post tomorrow like normal
you can actually click right here to get
it I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it and you can click here to learn
all about the wildlings thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives
[Music]